in this video we will consider a
classical application of Markov chains
which has to do with the design of a
phone system this is a classical problem
which was posed analyzed and solved by
Danish engineer by the name of Erlang
it was more than 100 years ago when
phones just started to exist but the
technique remains relevant today to
design systems of a similar nature as
for Elling he was trying to figure out
how to design the capacity of a phone
system that is how many lines should we
set up for a group of people say in a
village to be able to communicate to the
outside world so here is a cartoon of
the problem where these are the phone
lines and we need to decide how many of
these lines to set up let's say be how
to do that well we don't want B to be
too large much more than needed because
too many lines would be expensive on the
other hand we want to have enough lines
so that if a reasonable number of people
place phone calls during the same period
they will be able to talk and not get
busy signals so if B is 10 and 15 people
want to talk at the same time then 5
would get a busy signal and that's
probably not what you want as an
acceptable level of service so we would
like B to be just large enough so that
there is a high probability that no one
is going to get a busy signal so how do
we go about modeling a situation like
this well we need two pieces of
information one describing how phone
calls get initiated and once a phone
call gets started how long does it take
until it ends we are going to make some
very simple but somewhat plausible
assumptions we will assume that phone
calls originate as a Poisson process we
will assume that out of that population
there is no coordination at completely
random times people pick up their phone
and a penalty of each other's
also there is nothing special about
various times and different times are
independent so a Poisson mall is a
reasonable way of modeling a situation
and the dis assumptions we also assume
that the rate lambda is known or has
been estimated now it might be the case
that during the night the rate would be
different than during the day in that
case you would design the system to meet
the largest rate of the two for the
phone calls themselves we are going to
assume that the duration of a phone call
is a random variable that has an
exponential distribution with a certain
parameter mu so 1 over mu is the mean
duration of a phone call duration of
phone calls are independent between each
other
so here again we assume that the
parameter mu has been estimated for
example the mean duration one of em you
could be three minutes now is the
exponential assumption a good assumption
so here is the PDF of an exponential
random variable with parameter one of
the three that means that the mean
duration is about three minutes here so
if you look at this PDF it means that
most phone call will be kind of short
there is going to be a fraction of phone
call that are going to be larger and
then a very small fraction of phone
calls that are going to be even larger
so it sounds reasonable
however it's not exactly realistic in
some situations typically phone calls
that lasts a very short time are not
that common as opposed to what an
exponential distribution would indicate
here so some other distribution might be
better like this one for example here
where during a very small period of time
the wait a corresponds to this very
short period of time are kind of small
as well there are many distribution of
this type I've just provided here one
simple example this one is the Erlang of
parameter 2 and 2/3 what it means is
that it is the sum of 2
independent exponential random variable
and each one of them of parameter 2/3 so
the mean duration associated with this
distribution is also three minutes so
this might fit better some practical
situation but here we will keep the
simple assumption associated with an
exponential distribution all right so
let's try now to come up with a mouse
that we can decide how many lines B do
we want to set up the Poisson process
runs in continuous time and Col
durations being exponential random
variables are also continuous random
variables so it seems that we are in a
continuous time universe here is the
cartoon of the evolution of the system
so here I have in blue when phone calls
get initiated so this is called one
second one a third fourth and fifth one
and also I've represented here the
duration of the call so called one
lasted that long call to or lasted long
until here three up to here four here
etc so when you look at this kind of
system in that way and you run full time
in a continuous matter and here you have
zero line busy you have one line used
zero one then to become busy three two
one and zero and so on and so forth also
note that if I look at that system at
any time T because of our assumptions of
a Poisson process and an exponential
duration for phone calls and the
memoryless property associated with
these processes it means that the path
really has no information about the
future and so in some sense a Markov
property is valid so it looks like a
continuous time Markov process would be
needed here and this is indeed an option
but we have not studied those in this
class so we will discretize time instead
and work with a Markov chain
we are discretizing time in the family
way the way we did it when you we
studied the Poisson process we are going
to take the time
exists and split it into little discrete
time slots each of duration delta and
delta is supposed to be a very very
small number so now under this
discretization by the definition of the
Poisson process the probability that
we'll see one arrival during any time
slot of duration Delta will be lambda
times Delta also if at any time like
here we have one simple call active the
probability that this call will end
during any future time slot of duration
Delta is mu delta like here indeed as we
have seen in unit 9 an exponential
random variable can be thought of as
representing the time until the first
arrival of a Poisson process with rate
mu what if you have i busy calls at the
same time then the probability of adding
one call ending in a time slot of
duration Delta will be high mu delta
like for example here this one could
correspond to something as 2 mu delta
indeed each of the Poisson processes
associated with these skulls with rate
mu can be combined into a merge Poisson
process of rate I times mu and a call
completion will correspond to the time
until the first arrival of this merged
Poisson process for example if I go back
here in my situation here at time T
there were still three phone calls
active and I represent here the call
number to call number three and colon
before and their remaining duration and
if you look at these and you combine
these three associated Poisson process
into one you get a merged Poisson
process and if you look now at the time
arrival of the first event which would
correspond to here it would be an
exponential random variable the duration
here would correspond to an exponential
random
of parameter 3mu so in that case if you
go back to that representation here the
priority of a departure would be three
times mu times Delta okay so let us
continue with our discrete time
approximation of our system again we
have the village the lines the B that we
would like to decide we have discretized
the time steps we have made some
approximation and we know that during
any of these timeslot here the priority
that you would get a new call is about
lambda times Delta lambda is the rate of
the Poisson process and given that you
have I calls the rotor than one of these
calls
ends will be I times mu times Delta okay
if we want to propose a Markov chain
more for the system we need to specify
the states and the transition
probabilities what are the states of the
system if you look at the system at any
particular time the minimum relevant
information to collect would be the
number of busy lines something like
these two lines are busy or all of them
are busy or none of them are used now
because of our assumptions again but the
Poisson process arrivals an exponential
duration of calls and their memoryless
property that information is enough to
fully describe the state of our system
in such a way that we get a Markov chain
so the states are numbers from 0 to B 0
corresponds to a state in which all the
phone lines are free no one is talking B
corresponds to a case where all the
phone lines are busy
and then you've got States in between
now let us look at the transition
probabilities suppose that right now you
are in that state what can happen next
well a new phone call gets placed in
which case the state moves up by 1 or an
existing call terminates in which case
the state goes down by 1 or none of the
two happens in which case the state
stays the same well it is also possible
that the phone call gets terminated
and a new phone call gets placed in the
same time period but when the duration
of the timeslot are very very small the
Delta here this event is going to have a
negligible probability order of delta
squared so we ignore it as we ignore the
fact that more than one new call can
happen or more than one call can be
terminated during a given slot so what
is the probability of an upward
transition that's the priority that the
Poisson process has an arrival during
the slot of duration delta and as we
have seen this is lambda times Delta so
each one of this upward transition as
the same priority of lambda times Delta
how about phone call terminations if we
have iPhone calls that are currently
active the priority of that one of them
terminates becomes I mu delta so here it
would be mu delta and here b mu delta
now let us analyze this chain it has the
birth and death form that we discussed
in the previous lecture so instead of
writing down the balance equation in a
general form we think in terms of
frequency of transitions across some
particular cut in this diagram so for
example here the frequency with which
transition of this kind happen or are
observed has to be the same as the
frequency of transition of this kind the
frequency of transition of this type
will be if you look at PI I here and PI
of I minus 1 here this transition here
will happen with PI high times I mu data
and the transition of this type here
we'll be PI I minus 1 times lambda Delta
and the frequency of these transitions
have to be the same as the frequency of
these transitions so we have that equals
that and then we can cancel the Delta in
both and we are left with this equation
here so this equation expresses PI of I
in terms of PI of I minus 1 so if we
knew PI of 0 then we can calculate PI of
1 and then in turns calculate pi of 2
and so on and so forth and the general
formula that comes out of this after
some algebra is given by this expression
which involves PI of 0 now what is pi 0
well we can find it by using the
normalization equation summation of Pi I
equals 1 you use this normalization
replace each pi I by their quantities as
a function of Pi zero and then we obtain
this equation for pi zero so here again
we use that normalization we replaced pi
I by their value with sum to 1 and we
obtain PI of 0 and then in turn from
this PI of 0 you can replace the PI of 0
in PI of I and you obtain a PI of R as a
function of B lambda and mu so if we
know B and lambda and mu we can set up
this Markov chain and we can calculate
pi 0 and then PI of I for all eyes we
can then answer question like this after
the chain has run for a long time how
likely is it that at any given random
time you will find the system with high
Z line well it will be PI of I and also
we can interpret these steady-state
probabilities as frequencies so once I
found pi
I it also tells me what fraction of the
time I will have i busy lines and you
can answer that questions for every
possible I now we were initially
interested in the priority that the anti
system is busy at any point in time in
other words in that state here so if a
new phone call gets placed it is going
to find the system in a random state
that random state is described in steady
state by the probity PI's and the
probability that the anti system is busy
is going to be given by PI of B and this
is the probability that we would like to
be small in a well-engineered
system so again given lambda mu the
design question is to find B so that
this probability is small could we
figure out a good value for B by doing a
back-of-the-envelope calculation well
let's suppose that lambda is 30 calls
per minute and let's assume that mu is
1/3 so that the mean duration is 3
minutes so on average a call lasts for 3
minutes and you get 30 calls on average
per minute then how many calls would be
active on the average if a call lasted
exactly 1 minute then at any time you
would have 30 calls being active now a
call last on the average for 3 minutes
so by thinking in terms of averages you
would expect at any time there would be
about 90 calls that are active 3 times
30 and if 90 calls are active on the
average you could say okay I'm going to
set up my B to be 90 but that's not very
good because if the average number of
phone calls that want to happen is on
the average 90 sometimes you're going to
have 85 and some time you'll get 95 and
to be sure that the phone calls will go
through you probably want to choose your
beat to be a number allele
larger than 90 how much larger than 90
well this is a question that you can
answer numerically by looking at these
formulas if you decide that you're
acceptable level of service PI of B has
to be less than 1% then you will find
that the B that you need to design is to
be at least 106 so you actually need
some margin to protect against the
fluctuation if suddenly by chance more
people want to talk then on an average
day and if you want to have a good
guarantee that an incoming person will
have a very small probability of finding
a busy system here 1% then you will need
about 106 phone lines so that's the
calculation and the argument that
airline went through a long time ago
it's actually interesting that airline
did this calculation before Markov
chains were invented